this was supposed to be localism it
ended up being a weekend and a week were
shadowed by a new set of sex claims
going right back to the 60s it's been
pretty bizarre chain of events Isabel
what was happening what's going on say
over the weekend that the Rao owned this
missing dossier it was past the home
office is great
does he enter was it does they enter
child abuse claims say this was passed
to the Home Office but then disappeared
and canal not be found so Teresa Mays
going to give a statement today setting
out not just the QC who's going to be
investigating this particular dossier
where it's called and why it's
disappeared but also the wider
government response to the child abuse
route to the suggestion that there was a
Peter farrowing operating in Westminster
and the dossier the center of the
investigation as was it contains
allegations about Todd fees book child
abuse carried out by by politicians
allegedly this is this is a form that
was passed in the 1980s no one connected
activity which happened in the eighties
and the 70s involving people who are
active in public life in the 80s and but
I mean the question here is this is they
don't find the file now I don't think
that's necessarily proof of any great
conspiracy although obviously fans of
fame suppose people who do see some
massive cover-up going on here because I
mean if you look at the complete
shambles at the passport office you know
the idea of bureaucracy losing files
been unable to find things doesn't
necessarily prove wrongdoing but I think
what's happened is there's been such a
complete collapse in trust with um
pedophile priests
Jimmy Savile Rolf Harris that now all of
these things are almost taken as true
until proven to be false and this is
that the Pomona government has got
itself into is is in trying to prove
that there isn't anything going on
whenever you say there's nothing going
on people say oh that's a cover-up and
say that they say we're in this gonna
vicious circle where it's always
impossible for politicians to cut
on this this can public concern I think
what's going on is people are saying
well if I happened in the church if it
happened in the BBC if it happened in
the NHS you know what what's the last
institution left I mean it's Westminster
it's politics is this party political
I'll be effectively talking about Tories
here I mean I'm struck that the sort of
chief and protecting the Cedars Tom
Watson you know a very active labor and
campaign guy if he is the one throwing
stones you've got to wonder artifically
is just was in the front page of de
marsay has a allegation about a former
minister in the Blair government and
then one of the Sunday papers an
accusation a Labour peer so I didn't
this is uh this is pomp t political and
I think one of the things that the
leaves all three parties are aware
always that no one wants to be accusing
the other parties of some come to steal
involvement in this because they might
well have us have similar problems I'm
sorry I think it's him I think is
inherently faulty but it's cool i think
the party political element is also that
keeper of writing to threesome and
accusing her of a lack of leadership and
calling for the home office to respond
to calls that about keep apparently made
a year or so ago for a wider
investigation into child abuse so labor
are trying sort of snap at the Tories
fails politically on this issue but not
on this child these allegations so much
as the governor's response people say
that they want these people to justice
yet they're also saying that they want
to publicly quietly you can't have a
public enquiry and a police inquiry at
the same time there's also lots of a
pressure on online on Twitter in places
for people to name the people involved
you know use parliamentary privilege to
stand up and say he's been accused well
if those people are still living what
someone has stand up and use vomit
coverage to name them it's it's clearly
impossible than to get a fair trial and
that means that they will never be tried
and and and if found guilty convicted of
these offences I think your child abuse
is is the most horrific thing imaginable
but we need to avoid turning into Salem
and everyone everyone rushing to
conclude
desperately needed a comp right now I
think the other thing I would say here
which everyone should be very aware
office is is just remember the McAlpine
effect you know that was that was an
example of an allegation got going
people name someone involved on Twitter
and then journalists or other the bureau
of investigative journalism which isn't
quite the same thing I got really
excited and then we and it turned out
not to be true it ended up in a
situation where the doctor general of
the BBC had to resign
Sally burkas had to pay libel damages
I've become right and saying that the
soap soup so let's let's everyone just
take a deep breath and let's get to the
bottom of this but let's not do it in a
way that is reminiscent of sailor well
what ed miliband had hoped to talk to
you about today was about his new
localism policies in the piece in The
Guardian and it jumps out to me James
because this was language that Blair
could have been using you saying we're
going to devolve we believe we don't
like top-down instruction we believe in
people power so is he going back to the
sort of later.i agenda which is so M not
the mostly astute I I mean I something's
going on here which is this localism
agenda is one of our fault lines in the
Labor Party between the club the John
Kronus radicals and the spent deliver
more electoral pragmatists what do they
believe the so Cronus believes that he
wants everything sent locally um and
that you need services that are closer
to people if they're going to be more
responsive there's going to be more
democratic accountability now previously
the Treasury haven't liked this idea at
all but Ed Balls is is a surprising
convert to it because I think he's
realized but I'm a this ticks a ton of
radicalism box without spending money
and be it probably nails them to save
money in that it means someone else will
have to be some of the cuts some of
these town halls that have been given
responsibility will have to do some of
the things the extent to which this is
not a Blair I performance is very
noticeable that nobody's at David min
values still quite doubled evolution
Saudi religion both to individuals and
to town halls this is very much single
short evolution II is just of a town
halls so it's what we're talking about
transferring power from one bureaucracy
Westminster today but is there an
expectation you think that that the
people Leeds and Manchester are going to
reward them with votes because all the
politicians now are talking about this
it seems to be the book subjects yes it
is I think it's the idea that voters are
fed up of being powerless and that
someone saw my far away is taking a
decision on their behalf without really
taking into account what they want I
think also if you look at impressive
local authorities and cities that have
grown like Manchester they're really
ambitious councils that have been trying
to persuade central government to give
them more powers for years and
politicians like Hillary been John
Kronus we've been working on this in
labour have looked at Manchester and
thought well why can't we do what's
happened in Manchester for Stoke can
give them more pasture but you can look
at Birmingham where they've got lots of
power that was you know has been a
complete disaster
I mean Manchester is in the example of
Google local government Birmingham's a
disaster and very exactly very bad
disastrous little Goblin and he took
people in the Tories and Labour
privately one of the fears they do have
is that because the centre has taken so
much away from local government over the
past few decades the quality of person
working in local government is not as
good as it could be a lot more fund very
hard-working ambitious councillors but
if you're very ambitious and very
impressive you may head for the center
rather than staying in your town or your
city which means that there's a dearth
of talent in some local authorities to
be able to take on these powers but you
can't make an omelet without breaking
eggs and if you're going to hand over
those powers you instantly make local
government much more attractive because
you're not just making decisions about
bins and things that people who are
ambitious might think you're boring